[Applause]
nicole i hope to gosh you have speedy
with you
don't you worry speedy is right
here oh thank goodness
because i was like you know jeremy we
might look crazy if
nicole doesn't have speedy wait how old
is he because
jeremy is here i'll take her and by the
way jeremy is a girl
i love the name speedy by the way like
thank you so much i actually heard by
the way that speedy
i just got news from our um from
speedy's doctor
that speedy might be a girl
well you know what i have some
information to offer you
i am dr you're too little so like
oh my god dr drew little so
dr drew little found out that if you'd
like to figure out the sex of your
bearded dragon
here's how okay so under this part of
the tail
right there but underneath you will feel
a nub if it's a girl and a
prong if it's a boy
does it feel like it has like oh like a
wishbone
or a turtle a nub it's a nub speedy
you're a boy no then the nub is a girl
oh what yes speedy's a girl
speedy oh my god you know what
i love my children no matter who they
are no matter what sex they are
so i'm fine with it um has
jeremy the girl puffed out her beard at
you
um she has with lucky our cat
um in the dr drew little home
it's nuts and um
and uh jeremy and lucky the cat
they fully are besties
and um lucky will like lick
and kiss jeremy's face and every once in
a while jeremy will puff and just be
like
i've had enough feel for the nub or the
prong is gonna be my new
life motto we're going to do a double
feel after i'm going to
do it i'm going to check one more time
after we're done because
maybe now that i know i'm like okay and
by the way
if you shine a light on this side it
will come
through and it will illuminate the nub
or the prong
kind of like an x-ray okay
speedy we'll do this tomorrow because i
feel like this has been a lot for you
today
okay i want to talk to you about nikki
fresh
this is people are freaking out you
constantly like know how to hit with
things you just are such a taste maker
you have such impeccable style you're so
darn cool
and this i feel like is just the perfect
vehicle for you to put
everything into in this melting pot and
here out comes nikki fresh how did you
come up with the whole persona
well so it all started with um so i've
been i've had an edible garden
um i started that about six or seven
years ago
and the idea of gardening and growing
your own food was just something that
was very interesting to me and then
you know once i started doing it i just
like really
fell in love with it and my you know my
friends sometimes would make fun of me
like oh you're an old lady this isn't
cool you know whatever whatever
and i would be like how does gardening
have this reputation
i actually feel like it's the most cool
and exciting and like
how do i communicate to the masses how
like
amazing exciting spiritual like
gardening is and um i was like well
i think i have to do it through trap
music but then i was like
i can't do trap music i have too much
respect for the genre so i'm going to
create my own genre which is parent trap
which is people like us moms that love
music and love to have a good time
that's that's you and me drew
who love to have a good time and dance
but like i'm not up at 11 p.m
and you know so like my peak hour is in
the car
right after right after i drop off the
kids at school so
like you know i need music for that too
sometimes i feel like this is tapping
into
a part of me that was alive and well
many years ago and maybe hasn't totally
died
but wants to keep
midnight hours but like i'm still very
much the same person
and i love dancing you know i love that
you're saying this it makes me feel a
lot less crazy
for having my inner disco dolly still
intact
no my inner disco dolly is still right
here and
on this show with you oh i love it with
our beardies
with our beardies all up in the middle
of our
with our beardies i mean i used to this
is so
bad and embarrassing but i used i had a
snake named cleopatra of all python and
i used to take her to clubs
that is not only i mean that is so dope
i'm sorry it's very
it's very 90s early 2000s you know like
you